JEN PERSON: Hello.
I'm Jen Person for
"The Developer Show."
This is the first of your
weekly updates in 2019
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Cloud DNS forwarding is
now available in beta.
It allows you to create
bi-directional forwarding zones
between your on prem name
servers and Google Cloud
platform's internal
name servers.
The feature lists and a
link to the documentation
is on the post linked in
the description below.
Cloud SQL recently had
a couple of updates.
Private service access to
your Cloud SQL instances
is now generally available.
And there is now support for
connecting second generation
App Engine standard
environment run times
with Cloud SQL for Postgres.
Lots more details
are on the post.
And speaking of App
Engine, Python 3.7
is now generally available.
Cloud Spanner now has
enhanced query introspection,
new regions, and new
multi-region configurations.
You can get started
with the post.
Chrome 72 beta is now available
and allows declaration
of public class
field in scripts,
an API for querying whether
there has been user activation,
and lots more.
A full list and some
examples are on the post
linked the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
"The Developer Show."
Happy New Year, and
we'll see you next week.
It's almost Postgres,
which means dessert.
CREW PERSON: What means dessert?
JEN PERSON: Postgres.
CREW PERSON: Post race?
Oh, oh--
JEN PERSON: Like in Spanish.
CREW PERSON: I got you.